I am eating my feelings.
This is a very depressing
eating show.
Today, I have pizza
I'm gonna eat for you guys.
[ Voice breaking ]
This was not part of the plan.
The plan was for me to drink,
talk about dicks, and eat.
[ Sobbing ]
Food always
makes you feel better.
Mmm. Oh.
[ Sobbing ]
Oh, God.
Eating shit in front
of a huge audience
is usually
what Eli Manning does.
Why are so many of you
watching these videos?
There's good TV out there.
Not on this channel,
but out there.
The guy weeping into his noodles
is Nikocado Avocado,
and he's a mukbanger.
That sentence was
barely English.
Nikocado Avocado's not
his real name, but I love it,
so I'm gonna say
Nikocado Avocado
as much as possible.
Nikocado Avocado.
Maybe he calls himself
Nikocado Avocado
because his body is
turning into one.
Mukbanging is where lonely
people make videos of themselves
eating disgusting amounts
of disgusting food,
and then
even lonelier people watch them.
What makes
Nikocado Avocado special
is that he sobs over every meal,
which comes in handy
if you don't have a salt shaker.
If I want to see a depressed guy
slowly kill himself
by gorging on weird food,
I'd watch Anthony Bourdain.
Yeah, stop
with the new episodes, CNN.
But I don't need to exploit
a man's death for ratings,
so before we lose
Nikocado Avocado to diabetes,
I flew Nikocado Avocado to L.A.,
where everybody watches
what they eat,
for this week's
CeWEBrity Profile.
♪♪
Hey, Nikocado Avocado!
Daniel Mole Guacamole.
Nice to meet you.
Thanks for meeting me
at the complimentary
Hampton Inn
breakfast buffet.
Are you staying here?
No!
That's what
these robes are for.
Mmm.
You know,
I don't think
we're supposed to be sitting
at the buffet.
Why?
Because you don't sit
at the buffet.
A buffet's a bar.
You can sit at a bar.
I guess, but why do we have to
be here so early?
Because that's when the buffet
is at its hottest.
That's Hampton-ality.
Get you some forks.
Here you go.
All right.
Where are you from?
I'm from Columbia.
Are you really
from Columbia?
No, no, no.
I live there with my husband.
Hold on. I may have to try
some of these eggs.
Explain to me
what mukbanging is.
It's actually "mukbong."
It comes from Korea.
That sounds racist.
No.
"Mukbong."
You say it
like it's kind of racist.
I'm saying it how
they pronounce it -- "mukbong."
Like if you go to France,
you say I'm in Frah-nce.
You don't say Fraa-nce.
Le Frah-nce.
So, if I'm
in China I say,
[ bad Chinese accent ]
"I'm in China."
[ Normal voice ]
Is what you're saying?
So, "muck-bong."
The word means
"eating broadcast."
The idea was that they put
their camera down,
they filmed
themselves eating,
and then other people
would eat with them.
When do you jerk off?
It seems sexual.
Some people do that, but
that's not my target audience.
You're getting
millions of views.
I know, but not
from masturbators.
Do you want syrup?
On pancakes, sure.
That's plenty of syrup.
You didn't have to syrup
the [bleep] tongs.
Oh, I'm sorry.
That's for goddamn sure.
Don't worry about it.
I noticed in the beginning
of your videos,
you looked
a little bit smaller.
It's nice to be here.
And I'm gonna be doing this
a lot more regularly now.
Oh, yeah.
I've gained like, 50 pounds.
This isn't healthy.
I know it's not.
Let's figure out a way
to do this.
What about the amount of food?
Why is it so much?
Well, I mean,
it doesn't have to be a lot.
But I like to eat a lot
just 'cause.
No, but you're eating
an unhealthy amount.
You wouldn't eat that much
in a normal sitting, would you?
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
Right, so, why are you doing it
that amount of food?
'Cause it's a great excuse
to get fat. [ Laughs ]
How many videos
are you posting a week?
I post like
five days a week.
Five mukbang sessions
a week?
You're gonna die.
I know.
Ugh.
You're getting full
already?
Literally
getting full already.
You would never
be able to do this.
No, I wouldn't.
I would be for, like, the
premature ejaculator mukbangers.
Oh.
Ugh. [ Sighs ]
Getting hot.
But, yeah,
the food sweat.
By the way -- Why are you always
crying in your videos?
[ Sobbing ]
Are you that emotional?
I am. Well, the food
doesn't help, either.
Oh, 'cause
you just feel gross?
Well, you feel like shit.
But also, like, you're just --
It throws your hormones
out of whack.
And I'm already naturally
really emotional.
So, I just --
sometimes I cry.
What the [bleep]
was wrong
with that Alfredo pizza
you were eating?
The one in Columbia?
Yeah, it was big, and it was
flat, cheese looked hard.
Was I crying?
Yeah. Yeah, you were.
Of course
you were crying.
It tastes better
than it looked.
Hey, let me grab
one of those.
This?
Yeah.
That's raw waffle batter.
Isn't that bad for you?
Raw waffle batter?!
I thought this was
a waffle smoothie!
Tell me about how this has
affected your poops.
Are they enormous?
Yes.
People think I eat shit
all the time.
Well, just
a mukbang shit --
How long after one
of your videos before "uh-oh"?
It's usually immediate.
It's immediate?
Yeah, and it's not
the food I'm eating,
it's whatever's there
that gets pushed down.
Is it diarrhea,
or is it solid?
No. If I eat something that's
really spicy, then that hurts.
Yeah, you said
your butthole bleeds a lot.
It doesn't bleed,
but it hurts.
These fire noodles,
I'm obsessed with.
They really make
my a-hole bleed.
[ Belches ] Excuse me.
Not bleed, just sting --
Sting like a wasp.
Why fire noodles?
They're popular.
Running low
on eggs here!
If it wasn't popular -- the
Korean fire-noodle challenge --
I would not be on the toilet
crying twice a week.
[ Humming ]
Them good eggs are
on the bottom.
Mmm.
Hey, what's up
with the bird?
You shouldn't let your bird
eat that food.
That's bad for them.
I know, but
his name's Mr. Noodle.
Just 'cause his name
is Mr. Noodle
doesn't mean
he should eat noodles.
Okay, you caught me.
No one is gonna tell you
that feeding your bird
hot noodles
is a good idea.
Well, you know,
they can't feel spice.
They don't have
spice receptors.
I didn't know that.
Never mind.
Go ahead and feed him.
Why do you get hot sauce
in your eye so much?
I have no idea
why that happens.
I'm just
doing my video,
and hot sauce splatters
into my eyeball.
[ Breathing heavily ]
Every time.
Every [bleep] time.
Do you want me to tell you
why it's happening?
Why?
'Cause you [bleep]
sit so low.
If you had
a taller chair,
maybe your eyes would be
out of harm's way.
I don't know. I think I need to
get goggles from now on.
Can I have -- Pass me
the orange juice, please.
How long
have you been married?
Um, a year and a half.
Hi, everybody.
Look who I'm with.
The husband.
You still kiss,
or do you skip that?
No, we kiss.
What is this,
a mukbang gangbang?
Easy, spitfire.
We need some of these.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Hey, Peggy! These pancakes
already got syrup on them!
Peggy:
That's Hampton-ality!
That guy's doing
the heavy lifting for us.
Real piece of shit.
You seem to be riddled
with diseases,
but they're all self-diagnosed,
so I'm calling bullshit.
I don't know why I'm
in so much pain. [ Sniffles ]
And I don't want to go to a
doctor 'cause I have a phobia.
You said in your videos that you
have chronic coughing syndrome,
diabetes, kidney failure.
Okay, I thought
I had kidney failure.
I actually
turned out not to.
Okay.
And I thought
that I had diabetes.
I actually turned out
not to, too.
You eat that, uh --
that durian fruit.
Oh, I love durian.
That smells
like assholes.
It does.
Actually, my best friend
used to say it smells like
Indian food wrapped in a diaper.
[ Voice breaking ]
Gonna try to eat some durian.
It looks like a pastry
on camera.
They thought
it was dough.
It's so gross.
What's the texture like?
It's kind of like
scrambled eggs.
Ugh.
Is there any danger, outside of
just unhealthy eating?
There is
a lot of haters.
Actually, that's
one of the sole reasons
as to why I have
a lot of issues.
Like, they really
get to me.
Of course they do.
You have haters, right?
Mm.
What makes you sad
today?
I don't know.
I just -- Sometimes
when I've done a mukbang,
I feel full,
and then I just --
I think about all the stuff
in my life,
and I get...sad.
[ Sad piano playing ]
Are you gonna cry?
No.
[ Voice breaking ]
Maybe.
You want
to hug it out?
♪♪
Break it up, boys.
It's 10:00 A.M.
Breakfast is over.
But we're
still mukbanging.
It's okay.
I brought to-go boxes.
♪♪
All right,
Nikocado Avocado.
Let's go rinse off
in the pool.
All right.
After the pool,
we ate each other's boxes,
then took the courtesy shuttle
to the mall.
That's Hampton-ality.
One of these days,
Hampton Inn is gonna have to
pony up for all these
free plugs.